hier geht's weiter mit zwei
Gesetzentwürfen gleich zum einen zum
sogenannten
wohngeldplus-gesetz und zum anderen um
ein
heizkostenzuschussgesetz das Wohngeld
plus Gesetz wird eingebracht von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP kurz der ampelfraktion und das
heizkostenzuschussgesetz wird hier
eingebracht von der Bundesregierung
beide Gesetzgebungsverfahren beide die
beide Inhalte der jeweiligen Gesetze
hängen natürlich zusammen mit der
Energiekrise mit der energiekostenkrise
das Wohngeld plus war schon angekündigt
worden im Juli vom der Bundesregierung
es ist Teil des entlastungspaketes 3
eben so wie dann weiteren Verlauf der
Debatten auch noch mal über weitere
Heizkostenzuschüsse beispielsweise das
haben wir heute Nachmittag dann übrigens
auch noch mal
auf der Tagesordnung wenn es um eine
energiepreispauschale an
rentner-rentnerinnen
versorgungsbeziehende geht diese Debatte
sollte eigentlich beginnen
mit der
Bundesinnenminister mit der
bundesbahnministerin oder sehen wir sie
auch klarer geibels auf dem Weg zum Pult
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete die
hohen Energiepreise treffen viele
Menschen in Deutschland hart aber am
härtesten treffen sie doch diejenigen
die sowieso mit sehr wenig Geld
auskommen müssen und sie spüren das ganz
direkt in Ihrem eigentlich geschützte
Lebensumfeld nämlich der Wohnung die
Wohnung kostet bereits jetzt einen
großen Teil ihres Einkommens und
angesichts der stark gestiegenen Preise
bleibt am Ende nur noch sehr wenig zum
Leben sehr wenig auch zum Konsumieren
deshalb setzt das dritte
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung
genau hier an bei den Wohnkosten von
Menschen mit niedrigen Einkommen und
zwar zielgerichtet um keine Zeit zu
verlieren haben wir die beiden
Gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt die heute in
erster Lesung beraten werden und gerade
im bevorstehenden Winter schnell und
unbürokratisch helfen zu können sehen
wir vor wohngeldempfängern mit einem
zweiten Heizkostenzuschuss zu
unterstützen
dieser soll im Vergleich zum ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss deutlich erhöht
werden für einen Einpersonenhaushalt von
270 auf immerhin 415 Euro für ein
zweipersonen-haushalt von 350 auf ganze
540 Euro und für jede weitere Person im
Haushalt 100 Euro zusätzlich
wichtig ist dass auch erneut beziehen
nur von Leistungen nach dem BAföG und
Ausbildungs- und
berufsausbildungsbeihilfen von dieser
Hilfe profitieren und sie halten 200
statt 230 nun 345 Euro die Wohnkosten
sind jedoch so stark gestiegen dass
künftig noch mehr Menschen unsere
Unterstützung brauchen deshalb sehen wir
eine große Reform des Wohngeldes vor und
sie soll zum ersten ersten 2023 in Kraft
treten mit dem Wohngeld plus sehen wir
vor den Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
von bisher 600.000 Haushalte auf rund
zwei Millionen Haushalte mit immerhin
4,5 Millionen Menschen zu erhöhen
zugleich erhöhen wir die Zahlung
durchschnittlich von rund 180 auf rund
370 Euro pro Monat eine riesensteigerung
das heißt also mit dem Wohngeld plus
wird der Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
verdreifacht und durch die doppelte
durch die durchschnittliche Monatsrate
verdoppelt außerdem integrieren wir in
das Wohngeld künftig eine dauerhafte
heizkostenkomponente hierbei wird nicht
die Heizungsrechnung direkt bezahlt
sondern eine pauschale und auch das ist
ein wichtiger Anreiz zum Energiesparen
darüber hinaus führen wir einen Zuschlag
ein der berücksichtigt dass viele
Wohnungen in Kürze energetisch saniert
werden müssen und dadurch die Mieten
steigen werden das ist ein wichtiger
Beitrag für eine sozialgerechte
Klimawende
nicht zuletzt wird das Wohngeld auch
unbürokratischer und passgenauer wir
verlängern die möglichen
Bewilligungszeitraum von 12 auf 18
Monate und wir ermöglichen es den
Ländern einfache schnelle Auszahlung des
Wohngeldes vorzunehmen und wenn die
Mieter erhöht wird kann das Wohngeld in
Zukunft schon jetzt schon angepasst
werden wenn sie um 10 und nicht erst wie
jetzt um 15 Prozent steigt
das Wohngeld ist und bleibt eine der
zielgenauesten staatlichen
Unterstützungsleistungen überhaupt denn
es berücksichtigt gleichzeitig Einkommen
Haushaltsgröße und Wohnkosten übrigens
und das wissen viele nicht deswegen
werbe ich dafür auch um selbstgenutzten
Eigenheim
es erreicht somit exakt diejenigen die
es am dringendsten brauchen darunter
viele Alleinerziehende Menschen und das
ist mir auch wichtig Rentnerinnen und
Rentner sind fast die Hälfte der
wohngeldbeziehenden Haushalte und
Familien mit geringen Einkommen sowie
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner von alten und
Pflegeheimen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren der Gesetzentwurf für das
Wohngeld Plus ist die größte
wohngeldreform in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik er wurde innerhalb
kürzester Zeit auf den Weg gebracht und
ich weiß dieses für alle Beteiligten
auch für Sie natürlich ein großer
Kraftakt ich danke den Ländern für ihre
Unterstützung und für den intensiven
Austausch in den letzten Wochen genau zu
der Frage wie wir das möglichst
unbürokratisch organisieren und ich
danke den Kommunen vor allen Dingen den
Mitarbeitenden der wohngeldstellen die
sich jetzt schon vorbereiten auf die
vielen neuen Anträge und auch wenn wir
uns zügig an die Umsetzung machen werden
die Auszahlungen einige Zeit in Anspruch
nehmen wo wir als baumministerium mit
Vereinfachungen helfen können tun wir
das gerne und wo für die Länder
unterstützen können das Wohngeld digital
auszuzahlen wie es schon viele
Bundesländer auch tun helfen wir auch
sehr gerne ich bitte Sie nun
ich bitte Sie nun um konstruktive
parlamentarische Beratungen damit wir
die Betroffenen mit dem Wohngeld Plus
und dem Heizkostenzuschuss schnell und
verlässlich unterstützen können
herzlichen Dank
klarer geilwitz Bundesministerin für
Wohnen Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen mit
ihren Ausführungen zum Wohngeld plus
Gesetzes soll erhöht werden das Wohngeld
und es soll deutlich mehr Bezieher und
BezieherInnen geben in Zukunft wenn
dieses Gesetz in Kraft tritt Jan Marko
Luczak aus der Unionsfraktion ist der
erste gegenredner Sprecher für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
wir haben seit dem Beginn diesen
furchtbaren angetriebs auf die Ukraine
und der energiepreiskrise etwas was fast
schon so ein bisschen ein Schema der
Ampel ist wir haben die Situation dass
wir als Union Vorschläge machen für
notwendige Maßnahmen wir sehen aber dass
die Ampel dann zögert dass die zaudert
dass sie mal grün blinkt mal gelb
meistens steht sie aber auf rot und
irgendwann nach vier Streit auch in der
Koalition bewegt sich die Ampel dann
doch aber es ist dann zu spät
halbherzig und meistens ist es dann auch
noch mit handwerklichen Mengen versehen
das war beim Leistungspaket so beim
ersten das war beim ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss so das war und ist ja
immer noch bei der Frage der
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke so so war es bei der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Energieträger so ist es bei der
gasumlage die Moogs war so ist es beim
gaspreisdeckel wo wir immer noch nicht
genau wissen wie genau der ausgestaltet
ist wo jetzt nur klar ist das wird
irgendwann frühestens im März in Kraft
treten also nach dem Winter wo da finde
ich hat meine Kollegin Julia Klöckner
das gestern sehr gut gesagt das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn man jemanden nach
dem Winter sagt ich habe hier ein paar
tolle Winterreifen für dich möchtest du
nicht kaufen das ist viel zu spät die
Menschen brauchen jetzt Klarheit sie
brauchen jetzt eine Entlastung und da
kommen sie nicht hinterher liebe
Kollegin von der Ampel
und genauso ist es auch bei der Reform
des wohnen jetzt im März im März diesen
Jahres haben wir als Union in einem
Entschließungsantrag bereits gefordert
dass wir einen höheren Zuschuss bei den
Heizkosten brauchen dass wir die
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas senken müssen dass
wir eine Ausweitung des Kreises der
wohngeldberechtigung benötigen und dass
wir das Wohngeld koppeln müssen an die
Energiekosten
jetzt
Mitte Oktober 7 Monate später jetzt
ziehen sie als Ampel endlich nach das
ist viel zu spät sie haben über Monate
die Unsicherheit und die sorgen dann
Nöte der Menschen nicht ernst genommen
die warme Wohnung meine Damen und Herren
das darf doch nicht zu schuldenfälle
werden genauso wie ein Heizlüfter kein
Statussymbol sein darf und deswegen
müssen sie schneller sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
und jetzt will ich der einen Satz schon
sagen weil sie Frau Ministerin die
Kommunen angesprochen haben in Gedanken
haben dafür dass ich jetzt schon
vorbereitet ich weiß nicht ob sie mit
den Kommunen mal gesprochen haben ich
und ich weiß viele Kollegen aus meiner
Funktion haben das auch getan die wissen
überhaupt gar nicht wo Ihnen der Kopf
steht die wissen überhaupt gar nicht
wohin der Kopf steht weil das alles so
lange gedauert hat das ist ja heute
schon so dass in den wohngeldstellen ein
großer Antragsstau ist wenn sich aber
jetzt die Zahl der Wohngeld berechtigen
auf zwei Millionen fast mehr als
verdreifacht dann friert es an allem
dann fehlt es am Personal es fehlt ein
ausreichenden Büros es fehlt an der
technischen Infrastruktur nichts davon
konnte entsprechend vorbereitet werden
weil einfach keine Klarheit war weil es
jetzt sieben Monate später erst kommt
und deswegen muss man auch klar sagen
wenn das was jetzt geplant ist dass zum
ersten Januar 2023 die wohngeldreform
stehen soll in Kraft treten soll wirken
soll bei den Menschen ankommen soll das
wird vor aller Voraussicht nach nicht
funktionieren das ist aber dann nicht
die Schuld der Kommunen das ist die
Schuld dieser Bundesregierung die viel
zu spät gehandelt hat meine Damen und
Herren
und ich möchte Kritik vielleicht noch an
zwei drei Punkten festmachen weil sie ja
im Gesetzentwurf unter anderem in
Aussicht stellen dass das alles jetzt
vorläufig passieren soll also es sollen
vorläufige Auszahlung gemacht werden ich
habe mich dann so ein bisschen gefragt
was ist eigentlich der Inhalt dieser
vorläufigen Prüfung wenn wir mit
denjenigen spricht in den Kommunen die
das machen in den Wohngeld stellen dann
sagen die naja also ich weiß das auch
nicht so richtig die vorläufige Prüfung
entspricht im Kern eigentlich der
endgültigen Prüfung das bedeutet dann
aber eben wieder dass sie nicht einen
Verwaltungsvorgang haben dass sie einmal
gucken hat jemand den Anspruch auf
Wohngeld und dem das dann aussieht nein
sie haben zweimal den gleichen Vorgang
sie müssen erstmal vorläufig prüfen und
es am Ende dann noch mal endgültig
prüfen aber mit dem gleichen Schemata
damit verdoppeln Sie den Personalaufwand
damit verdoppeln Sie den Aufwand und die
verdoppeln damit am Ende auch die
Probleme das ist nicht in Ordnung damit
schaffen sie nur Verunsicherung meine
Damen und Herren
und auch handwerklich und auch
handwerklich hat ihr Vorschlag viele
Menge ich will das nur mal an der
Systematik der mietenstufen festmachen
die ja für die Berechnung des wohngeld
ist ganz zentrales da sagen sie zum
Beispiel das würde es geändert werden da
sagen sie zum Beispiel dass die Stadt
Münster wohin jeder weiß wie die
Wohnungsmarktsituation in einer
Studentenstadt wie Münster ist nämlich
außerordentlich angespannt da sagen sie
Münster das soll gleich behandelt werden
von der Mietenstufe wie Mülheim an der
Ruhr oder wie Pirna das kann man doch
keinem erzählen man weiß man muss doch
nur einmal gucken wie die Mieten
Situation sich dort darstellt das passt
doch überhaupt nicht zusammen das hat
schon was mit Realitätsverweigerung zu
tun was sie ja machen aber mit
Realitätsverweigerung hat die
bauministerin ja spätestens seit dem
Bündnis zu bezahlbaren Wohnort auch ein
bisschen Erfahrung über Monate hat man
das Ziel von 400.000 Wohnungen wie eine
Monstranz vor sich hergetragen jeder
wusste eigentlich dass das nicht
realistisch war hat aber monatelang
trotzdem das aufrechterhalten bislang
auf einer falschen Tatsachengrundlage
verhandelt und damit am Ende verhindert
das Richtige und auch schwierige
Entscheidung getroffen waren ich kann
nur sagen beim Wohngeld bei den
mietenstufen wie auch an vielen anderen
Stellen mehr Realität würde dieser Ampel
gut tun meine Damen und Herren und
vielleicht noch einen letzten Punkt den
ich sagen möchte weil der auch mir
wichtig ist eine klimakomponente
einzuführen beim Wohngeld das ist
richtig dass man eine energetischen
Zustand anknüpft das ist richtig dass
man das belohnt wenn ein Vermieter
energetisch saniert und das das
natürlich weil es am Ende eben auch
höhere Mieten bedeutet im Wohngeld sich
widerspiegeln müssen auch das ist
richtig
nur davon steht in ihrem Gesetz nicht
sie führen zwar eine klimakomponente ein
aber der energetische Zustand eines
Gebäudes also das wo es darauf
eigentlich darauf ankommen sollte bei
der klimakomponente der spielt überhaupt
keine Rolle jeder ganz pauschal bricht
diesen Zuschlag das ist eine
Mogelpackung genauso wie dieser CO2
Bepreisung was sie jetzt hier als
Vorschlag gemacht haben worüber sie
jetzt in der Ampel streiten das ist eine
Mogelpackung das kann so nicht bleiben
meine Damen und Herren
und deswegen lassen sie mich zum Schluss
nur sagen wir unterstützen als Union
ausdrücklich die Reform des wohngeld ist
wir dürfen die Menschen in dieser
Energiekrise nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen nutzen Sie jetzt diese
verbleibenden Wochen mit aller
Ernsthaftigkeit die Einkommen richtig zu
definieren Bagatellgrenzen bei
Rückforderung einzuführen ins Klima
Komponenten zu machen die wirklich ihren
Namen verdient damit werden sie dem Lage
dem Ernst der Lage gerecht das was sie
hier vorgelegt haben das wird der Lage
tatsächlich nicht gerecht und deswegen
können wir das so in der Form nicht
mittragen vielen Dank mein Damen und
Herren
Jan marco lucczak war das für die Union
und er kritisiert dass dieses Wohngeld
plus-gesetze nicht sozial genug
gestaffelt sei dass jeder
der Anspruch darauf hat egal wie der
Zustand der Wohnung ist oder des Hauses
indem er wohnt Julia verlinken
stellvertreten Fraktionsvorsitzende
wo sprechend ich kann mich an einen
Minister ihrer Partei erinnern der hatte
nach Monaten noch nicht mal einen
Staatssekretär dahingegen haben wir hier
ein neues Bauministerium mit dieser
Koalition gegründet und dieses
Bauministerium hat bereits Anfang des
Jahres ein Heizkostenzuschuss als
Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt den wir
innerhalb weniger Wochen hier
beschlossen haben und noch ein paar
Wochen später hatten die Menschen das
Geld auf ihrem Konto also insofern
bleiben sie mal bei der Wahrheit die
aktuellen Energiepreise machen uns allen
zu schaffen das ist klar und es gibt
Menschen die sind sehr viel härter davon
betroffen als die allermeisten hier in
diesem Raum und genau diesen Menschen
die hat getroffen sind weil sie bereits
jetzt hohe Mieten zahlen müssen im
Vergleich zu ihrem Einkommen diesen
Empfängerinnen und Empfänger von
Wohngeld die wollen wir mit diesem
Gesetz unter die Arme greifen aber da
hören wir nicht auf wir erhöhen nicht
nur das Wohngeld sondern wir erweitern
auch sehr deutlich den Kreis der
Berechtigten denn die Mieten explodieren
in zahlreichen Städten und die stellen
zum Beispiel Familien vor große
finanziell Herausforderungen trotz
festem Einkommen und zwei Millionen
Haushalte die künftig deswegen das
verbesserte Wohngeld beantragen können
das ist ein richtig großer Fortschritt
das eine Verdreifachung und dafür vielen
herzlichen Dank für den Vorschlag
gleichzeitig bringt der erneuten in
Heizkostenzuschuss auf den Weg damit
helfen wir den Beziehern von Wohngeld
aber eben auch bafög-empfängerinnen
berufsausbildungsbeihilfen und
Ausbildungsgeld die ampelregierung setzt
so ein klares Zeichen wir lassen die
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen nicht im
Stich und klar ist auch das Wohngeld ist
ein wichtiges soziales und
unverzichtbares Instrument aber es packt
das Problem nicht an der Wurzel mit
dieser Förderung unterstützen wir
natürlich die Menschen die es brauchen
wir finanzieren indirekt aber natürlich
auch die zum Teil viel zu hohen Mieten
in unserem Land und da müssen wir ran
und da gehen wir auch ran und dazu sage
ich Ihnen jetzt gerne was wir nämlich
noch vorhaben in diesem Richtungswechsel
wir hatten ja beim Thema bezahlbarer
Wohnraum und Sozialwohnungen im Jahr
2006 noch zwei Millionen von diesen beim
Regierungswechsel letztes Jahr waren es
nur noch 1,1 Millionen Sozialwohnungen
und das geht nicht mit mehr sozialen
Wohnungsneubau und einer neuen
wohngemeinnützigkeit können und werden
wir als Ampel gegensteuern und dabei
geht es nicht nur um den Neubau es gibt
zahlreiche Möglichkeiten vorhandene
Gebäude auch besser zu nutzen auszubauen
zu reaktivieren viele Kommunen und
Wohnungsgenossenschaften haben damit
angefangen sie haben zum Beispiel
wohnungstauschprogramme etabliert so
dass zum Beispiel die wachsende Familie
mit der alleinstehenden Dame die Wohnung
unterschiedlicher Größe tauschen kann
sofern das beide wollen und so nutzen
wir vorhandene Wohnungen sinnvoll aus
auch anbauen oder beispielsweise
Dachgeschosse ausbauen dort neuen
Wohnraum zu ermöglichen ist ein ganz
wichtiger Beitrag dazu
ressourcenschonend und zügig
zusätzlichen Platz zu schaffen
fossile Heizenergie ist teuer und
widerspricht den Klimazielen im
Gebäudesektor entsteht rund ein Drittel
des gesamten co2s in Deutschland deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine strukturelle
Veränderung in der Wärmeversorgung das
ist klar die energetische Ertüchtigung
und tiefer gehende Sanierung unserer
Gebäude muss in der Prioritätenliste
weiter nach oben steigen es geht um
Energieeffizienz es geht um erneuerbare
Wärme und nur so können wir die
Mieterinnen und Mieter vor weiteren
Preissteigerungen wirklich nachhaltig
schützen und vermeiden dass der
Heizkostenzuschuss eine Dauerlösung
werden muss und auch dieser Punkt ist im
Wohngeld mitgedacht mit einer
klimakomponente gleichen wir eventuelle
Mietanpassung nach einer Sanierung aus
gleichzeitig unterstützen wir ja auch
die vermieter:innen und
Gebäudeeigentümer mit zielgerichteten
Fördergeldern in der Gebäudesanierung im
Haushalt stellen wir hierfür
Milliarden in zweistelliger Höhe bereit
weil sie eine sinnvolle Investition sind
so wird ein klimaneutraler
Gebäudebestand in greifbares Ziel bei
der alle alle Beteiligten mitgenommen
werden und davon profitieren herzlichen
Dank
Julia verlinken war das die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Bündnis grünen um die Bürger bereits
in diesem Jahr angesichts der
gestiegenen Energiekosten zu entlasten
soll es für die Heizperiode von
September bis Dezember einen einmaligen
Heizkostenzuschuss geben er beläuft sich
bei einem zwei Personenhaushalt zum
Beispiel auf 540 Euro
Roger bekämpfen jetzt für die AFD
erhalten und die entsprechenden Ausgaben
werden mehr als verdreifacht Wohngeld
richtet sich ein Haushalte mit Einkommen
Altersrenten oder auch Empfänger von
ALG1 bis zu einer bestimmten Höhe wobei
diese Einkünfte für die
wohnkostenbelastung eben nicht
ausreichen inhaltlich geht es bei dieser
Reform im Wesentlichen um Heizkosten und
angehobene Einkommensgrenzen all dies
führt dazu dass die Leistungen für
wohngeld-empfänger deutlich erhöhen so
macht alleiner neuerdings vorgesehenen
Zuschuss für den Heizkosten und zwei
Euro 30 je Quadratmeter im Monat gibt es
hier aus zudem steigt die Zahl der
Anspruchsberechtigten deutlich so bekam
ein einpersonen deshalb bisher Wohngeld
bei einem Einkommen von gut 1.800 Euro
brutto nun darf man sogar 2.300 Euro
verdienen und bekommt Wohngeld die
Anzahl der Haushalte die Wohngeld
erhalten steigt damit um 1,4 Millionen
auf dann gut 2 Millionen Haushalte damit
werden auch Teile der unteren
Mittelschicht erreicht und weil das
ganze erst zum ersten Januar 2023 in
krafttritt gibt es noch einmal einen
weiteren Heizkostenzuschuss für
zahlreiche Bezieher von Wohngeld und
anderen Sozialleistungen dieses Jahr
klingt das gut für sie gerade in Zeiten
hoher Inflation und stetig steigende
Energiepreise
aber warum haben wir denn überhaupt so
einen hohen Bedarf an Sozialleistungen
bis in die Mittelschicht denn genau das
ist das Wohngeld eine andere Art der
Sozialhilfe bisher braucht die
menschlich zu etwas nicht wofür ist das
ein Symptom also was liegt dahinter was
sind die Ursachen Null die Nebenkosten
vieler Wohnungsnutzer sind zu hoch diese
bestehen vor allen Dingen aus Heizkosten
die derzeit bekanntermaßen eine Richtung
kennen nach oben wir erinnern uns früher
war alles besser Gasstrom und so weiter
waren bezahlbar die Nachfrage ist zwar
ähnlich wie früher aber das Angebot ist
massiv gesunken also steigen die Preise
die Leute haben wegen des angebots-shops
im Bereich der Energie sowieso schon
weniger Geld in der Tasche und viele
können ihre steigen Heizkosten nur noch
schwer tragen hier ist wohl eine
gemischte ursachenbilanz festzustellen
also eine Art Putin Habeck Scholz
Gaspreis Pedal daher auch die
gaspreisbremse
und die Mieten nun hier ist genau
andersherum aber mit dem gleichen
Preiseffekt das Angebot ist ähnlich wie
früher aber ihn Nachfrage ist massiv
gestiegen also steigen auch hier die
Preise genannt mieten es gab einen
nachfrageschock so das Wohnungen fehlen
und woher kommt dieser nachfrageschock
Zitat
die Überlastung der Kommunen die
mögliche Überforderung unserer
Sozialsysteme oder eine Begrenzung des
flüchtlingsstromes finden weder im
würdigen noch im Handeln der
Bundesregierung auch nur ansatzweise
Berücksichtigung es ist nicht
nachvollziehbar dass die Bundesregierung
in Zeiten ohnehin hoher zugangszahlen
zusätzliche freiwillige
Aufnahmeprogramme für Flüchtlinge
startet oder mit Leistungsverbesserungen
für Asylbewerber oder mit der Einführung
des sogenannten Chancen
Aufenthaltsrechts noch mehr Anreize
setzt ins Land zu kommen Zitat Ende
könnte das vielleicht stimmen ich weiß
gar nicht genau aber was meinen Sie
das sagte jedenfalls der bayerische
Innenminister Hermann mit Blick auf den
sogenannten flüchtlingsgipfel vor
einigen Tagen Millionen Menschen strömen
abermals derzeit unser Land und wieder
ist Zitat
diese Zuwanderung aus Drittstaaten das
zeigen viele Studien im günstigsten Fall
ein Nullsummenspiel in den meisten
Berechnungen
ist sie ein Kostenfaktor ihrer
Faktenlage pulfaktoren meist geht es um
Flüchtlinge oder um Heiratsmigration das
sind in der Regel eher schlecht
ausgebildete Leute aus Ländern die eine
große wenn ich gar die größte mögliche
kulturelle Distanz zur Europa haben
viele beziehen Sozialleistungen tragen
damit auch nicht im positiven Sinne zu
Gesellschaft und zu Wirtschaft bei Zitat
Ende so Ruth koopmanns Leiter der
Abteilung Migration am
Wissenschaftszentrum für Sozialforschung
in Berlin kürzlich an Beitrag der Neuen
Zürcher Zeitung so viel zu Wissenschaft
bei Damen und Herren
und genau diese Leute bekommen den
Wohnraum den einheimische dringend
brauchen und müssen in der Regel nicht
einmal selbst dafür bezahlen fast
900.000 der Einwanderer ihre Einwanderer
von 2015 und 2016 und Sie können mich da
gerne bescheuerten nennen aber es bleibt
ja ein Fakt beziehen Hartz IV oder
andere Sozialleistungen diesmal hat
Putin damit nicht zu tun das ist allein
Verschulden dieser Regierung und der
Vorgängerregierung
und deswegen meine Damen und Herren
brauchen wir in dem der gaspreisbremse
eine migrationsbremse zu einfach kann es
sein denn dieses Land muss sich ändern
von einem Paradies für asylanwanderer
ohne Schutzbedürfnis die meisten haben
gar kein Schutzbedürfnis muss dieses
Land zu einer Wüste für diese Menschen
werden die eben nicht schutzbedürftig
sind das sind wir den deutschen und
allen Einheimischen allen anderen auch
hier die lange gerne hier leben sollen
schuldig nichts aber sind wir schuldig
den Roma-Familien Usbeken und den
tausend anderen Drittstaaten die die
Lage noch keine ausnutzen und über diese
in unser Land kommen und nicht schuldig
sind wir auch die Hunderttausenden die
aus dem Nahen Osten und Afrika kommen
diese Menschen suchen keinen Schutz bei
uns
diese hätten sie in ihren Nachbarländern
schon längst befinden können nein sie
suchen und finden unserem Land Wohnungen
Sozialhilfe
und dank Ihrer Hilfe
Staatsbürgerschaften genau das hält
diese Regierung auf Kosten der
einheimischen für Sie bereit und die
eigenen Leute und die eigenen Leute
erhalten dann ein bisschen mehr Wohngeld
als sozialkosmetik herzlichen
Glückwunsch aber ich verrate ihn ein
Geheimnis die Politiker eines Landes
sind zuallererst zum Schutz und Nutzen
des eigenen Landes da und nur mal als
kontrollfrage wie lange wollen Sie uns
so weitermachen in Afrika kommen alle 11
Tage alle 11 Tage eine Million Menschen
dazu einfach mal googeln alle 11 Tage
eine Million Menschen kommen dazu die
geboten Raten sind astronomisch alleine
bevölkerungsafrikas verdoppelt sich bis
2050 von 1,2 auf 2,5 Milliarden wie
viele wollen Sie hier davon noch Schaden
einige haben bestimmt ein paar Wohnungen
in Ferienhaus bringen Sie doch gerne zu
sich nach Hause und es ist auch Wahnsinn
so hat es doch System wir
subventionieren auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
gegen eine selbstverschuldete
migrationsbedingte Knappheit an ganz
ähnlich wie bei der Energie und genauso
trifft es auch hier eher die
einkommensschwächeren Teile unseres
Volkes diese Reform ist wohngelds mit
all ihre Milliarden ist zwar vital nötig
aber nur deshalb weil ihre Politik die
entsprechenden Probleme erst
hervorgerufen hat diese Reform ist
letztlich nur ein weiteres Zahnrad im
Reparaturbetrieb ihrer Politik ihre
Politik macht weite Teile unseres Volkes
der Mittelschicht sozialbedürftig ihre
Politik ist zutiefst unmoralisch und
inländerfeindlich sichere Grenzen
bezahlbarer Wohnraum
der Bundestag debattiert über das
wohngeldplus-gesetz und den Heizkosten
Zuschuss und der nächste Redner hier
kommt von der FDP Daniel Vöst Sprecher
für Bau und Wohnungspolitik werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also wie völlig
egal der AFD die akuten Nöte der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Deutschland
sind und wie völlig egal im Herrn Becker
und die akut Nöte sind zeigt er dass er
lieber über Flüchtlinge redet als über
die sorgen unsere Menschen
ziemlich gut an dem Beitrag war es war
der einzige Beitrag der AFD in der
debattet weil wir sind tatsächlich in
schwierigen Zeiten wir bekommen das ja
mit die Menschen spüren sie haben Angst
kann ich Strom noch zahlen kann ich
Heizungen noch zahlen es ist dringend
nötig dass wir aktiv werden und deswegen
handelt ja auch die ampelregierung wir
versuchen nicht nur Strom zu sparen
insbesondere Industrie sondern wir
entlasten auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die vor Überlastung Angst haben
die vor der Überlastung stehen deswegen
kommt ja die gaspreisbremse deswegen
kommt ja die strompreisbremse deswegen
gibt es ja die energiepreispauschale
deswegen werden auch Steuerentlastungen
ausgereicht das ist ja alles alles
richtig und wichtig und dazu gehört
nämlich auch
das Wohngeld deutlich zu erhöhen und
weil die weil die Union mich gerade
fragt wie sieht es denn aus meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren es sieht
leider so aus dass wir als Ergebnis
einer völlig blauäugigen Politik in eine
totale Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas
geraten sind so sieht's aus und ich muss
es jetzt einfach mal hier sagen weil es
mittlerweile auch in Frage gestellt wird
es ist
für ein Gas mehr beziehen es ist
vollkommen richtig in keiner Sekunde
stelle ich dieses Sanktionen in Frage
nur wir baden geradeaus was uns
hingelegt wurde also aber zurück zurück
zum Wohngeld ich es tut mir es tut mir
leider ich versuche es ja zu vermeiden
immer zu erwähnen dass ihr uns das
eingebrockt habt aber ihr bettelt ja
drum nee so also und jetzt werden wir
jetzt werden wir das Wohngeld deutlich
erhöhen und deutlich ausweiten und wir
Freie Demokraten wir sind bekennende
Fans des wohngelds weil es eine sehr
zielgenaue Hilfe ist weil es genau den
Menschen Hilfe gibt die Hilfe brauchen
für die Dauer in der sie Hilfe brauchen
und deswegen stehen wir
mit Begeisterung hinter diesem Wohngeld
ich persönlich sage es ist besser den
Menschen direkt zu helfen als allzu viel
Geld in Beton zu verbauen weil was
direkt ankommt und was sofort ankommt
für die Dauer in das benötigt wird ist
es besseres System
deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass wir
das Wohngeld Zukunft fit machen das
spielt die heizkostenkomponente
natürlich eine Rolle es ist wichtig die
Heizkosten steigen brauche ich Ihnen
nicht sagen es ist wichtig dass wir die
klimakomponente mit aufnehmen das ist
wichtig und das wichtigste finde ich ja
Herr Luc sie beschweren sich über die
Bürokratie da entsteht aber in ihrer
Rede fordern sie in einer Tour mehr
Bürokratie wird doch natürlich wir
müssen das noch rein tun wir müssen das
noch einführen und dann müssen wir noch
Rückzahlung machen und das müssen sie
haben sechs Punkte aufgezählt wo mehr
Bürokratie ins Wohngeld kommt und
beschweren sich dann bei uns dass die
Kommunen es vielleicht nicht leisten
können und natürlich werden wir den
Kommunen und den Ländern helfen müssen
dieses Wohngeld auszuzahlen es ist uns
ja bewusst dass es nicht einfach ist
deswegen haben wir ja oder hat die Frau
Ministerin Entbürokratisierung mit ins
Wohngeld reingepackt deswegen gibt es
die Möglichkeit erstmal
Abschlagszahlungen zu gewähren deswegen
gibt es ja mittlerweile auch das System
eines digitalen monatsantrags der frage
mich doch in der frage mich doch
insbesondere auch als Bayer in Bayern
Herr Kiesling warum ist in Bayern eine
Wohngeldantrag nicht komplett digital
wir haben mittlerweile ein System dass
man nutzen kann und wenn Kommunen Hilfe
brauchen einen digitalisiertes System
bei Google einzuführen bin ich mir
sicher werden wir auch noch Hilfe
leisten können und müssen weil das was
wir jetzt digitalisieren das wird auch
auf Dauer digital bleiben
zum Abschluss
zum Abschluss ein wichtiger Punkt der
Klang auch teilweise oder Debatte schon
an
wir sind in einem System gerutscht und
das ist wirklich bedenklich ich rede
jetzt nicht von den letzten 16 Jahren
aber trotzdem wir sind in ein System
gerutscht das ist bedenklich
es ist fast unmöglich für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft für diejenigen die so
gerade in der Mittelschicht angekommen
sind sich wohnen leisten zu können es
wird immer schwieriger deswegen warten
wir auch das Wohngeld aus aber es kann
ja nicht sein dass wir ein System haben
dass ich entweder auf der einen Seite
beim bauernhoch subventionieren oder auf
der anderen Seite bei den Wohnkosten
hoch subventioniere wir müssen für die
Mitte Gesellschaft ein System haben das
von allein heraus bezahlbaren Wohnraum
schafft und da ist es Bündnis für
bezahlbaren wohnraumministerin eine
wirklich richtige Antwort wir müssen mit
den Baukosten runter wir müssen mit den
Genehmigungsverfahren schneller werden
wir müssen schauen dass wir mehr
günstiger und schneller bauen weil wir
nicht auf Dauer einen großen Teil der
Gesellschaft entweder beim Bauen
subventionieren können oder bei
wohnsubventionieren können das Wohngeld
ist absolut notwendig aber damit ist nur
der erste Schritt getan wir werden noch
viel mehr machen müssen damit wir wieder
als System haben das günstigen Wohnraum
aus sich heraus zur Verfügung stellt
vielen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen bevor ich
dem nächsten Redner der nächsten
Rednerin das Wort gebe komme ich noch
einmal zurück zum Zusatzpunkt 3 wir
haben das Protokoll geprüft und ich
erteile dem fraktionslosen Abgeordneten
Matthias Helferich einen Ordnungsruf
wir fahren jetzt fort in unserer Debatte
und als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort
Karin live für die Linke
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
die Reform des Wohngeldes ist überfällig
und sie ist dringend nötig deswegen
haben wir das als Linke auch mehrfach
gefordert und konkrete Vorschläge hier
in dieser Stelle eingebracht
deswegen freut es uns dass es endlich
angegangen wird doch leider bleibt ihr
Entwurf unzureichend und Stückwerk
lange Zeit galt es als unbeschriebenes
Gesetz in diesem Land das niemand mehr
als 30 Prozent des Einkommens für das
Wohnen ausgeben muss warm die Realität
ist heute eine andere schon jetzt geben
12 Prozent der Haushalte mehr als 50
Prozent aus kalt mit der Energiekrise
werden es noch deutlich mehr werden
dieser Zustand ist völlig inakzeptabel
niemand darf mehr als 30% des Einkommens
für das Wohnen ausgeben das sind die
Grundfesten unseres Sozialstaates und
das müsste eine wohngeldreform auch
leisten
aber nein sie machen eine
wohnkostenbelastung von 40% zu Maßstab
und das ist völlig inakzeptabel
und außerdem wird das Wohngeld immer
noch klein gerechnet also wenn man nur
die Mieten der Wohngeld Haushalte zum
Grundlage der Berechnung nimmt also von
Leuten mit sehr wenig Geld dann verzerrt
das doch völlig die Realitäten man
müsste also die Marktmieten zur
Grundlage nehmen und das Ergebnis dieser
kleinen rechten Reihe bedeutet ganz
konkret dass 187 Gemeinden herabgestuft
werden in den sogenannten mietstufen
also zum Beispiel auch Städte wie
Chemnitz oder Bautzen das heißt hier
werden die Zuschüsse praktisch gesenkt
durch ihre Reform das ist doch wirklich
absurd
und wenn sich in der Kritik an den miet
Stufen Herr Lutscher von der CDU und ich
einig sind zum ersten Mal nach zehn
Jahren dann müsste ihnen das doch
wirklich zu denken geben
und unsere Kritik die Teilchen nicht nur
der Deutsche Mieterbund sondern auch der
deutschen Städte und Gemeindetag und die
sagen lassen Sie uns doch endlich Zitat
die empirisch gefestigten Grundlagen
einführen zur Berechnung der mietstufen
also das ist doch wohl wirklich klar ich
bitte darum
meine Damen und Herren haben Sie schon
mal einen Wohngeldantrag gesehen also es
sind acht komplizierte Seiten fünf
Seiten Erläuterungen 47 Unterpunkte das
überfordert viele Menschen die
Ämter kommen jetzt schon hinterher und
haben nicht das Personal die ihre Reform
umzusetzen
längere bewegungszeiträume das finden
wir gut aber besser wäre es die bereits
bewilligten Anträge zunächst um ein Jahr
zu bewilligen dann könnten sich die
Behörden vollkommen auf die Bearbeitung
der neuen Anträge konzentrieren
immerhin ist salzkostenzuschuss pauschal
das begrüßen wir aber in vielen Decken
deckt er nicht die an vielen Stellen
entdeckte nicht der realen Bedarfe und
was ich wirklich auch dann wirklich
unakzeptabel finde wir haben ja
gleichzeitig noch den CO2-Preis der
immer noch alleine von dem Mieterinnen
und Mietern bezahlt wird das heißt wenn
drei Personen Haushalt mit einer
Ölheizung reduziert sich der
Heizkostenzuschuss dann locker von 640
Euro auf nur noch 450 Euro also das
reicht doch dann bei weitem nicht aus
meine Damen und Herren das
grundsätzliche Problem kann keine
wohngeldreform leisten nämlich
mietenwahn sind und Spekulation viele
beziehende von Wohngeld die wohnen doch
bei vonovia bei LED bei den großen
privaten Konzernen und denen schmeißen
wir jetzt natürlich mit so einer Reform
das Geld am Ende des Tages auch noch
hinterher deswegen kann eine
wohngeldreform nicht das einzige und
auch nicht das zentrale Instrument sein
wir brauchen endlich einen mietenstopp
lassen Sie uns das Problem bei den
Wurzeln packen
deswegen brauchen wir ein Krisenpaket
Miete das heißt schutzverkündigungen
Schutz vor Zwangsräumungen Verbot von
indexmieten und ja wir brauchen einen
mietendeckel und einen Deckel für Strom
und Gaspreise das fordern wir als LINKE
das hilft gegen Spekulation gegen
Inflation und kommt den Staat auch nicht
zu teuer zu stehen vielen Dank
Karin leiert mal gerechnet von der
Linken Sprecherin vermiedenbau- und
Wohnungspolitik die nächste Rednerin
kommt von der SPD ist die zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Verena Huberts
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau bauministerin Gallwitz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden
heute hier über eine große
wohngeldreform aber was sind das
eigentlich für Menschen für die wir das
tun und mein Wahlkreis das ist Trier und
da gibt es auch einige denen diese
Reform zugute kommt es gibt zum Beispiel
den Rentner der hat damals so viel
verdient dass er sich jetzt nicht
unbedingt viel sparen konnte für die
Rente und der zahlt 500 Euro kalt in
einem Trierer Stadtteil nicht mal
Innenstadtlage und gibt mehr als die
Hälfte seiner Rente für die Miete aus
es gibt die alleinerziehende Mutter und
viele können nur ahnen wie
herausfordernd das Leben ist wenn man
natürlich dann auch in Teilzeit arbeitet
und damit nicht oder nur mit Mühe und
Not über die Runden kommt und das sind
Lebensrealitäten für viele Menschen in
unserem Land das sind Leute die hart
arbeiten und die hart gearbeitet haben
und für diese Leute machen mehrere Euro
mehrere hundert Euro im Monat den
Unterschied auch aus den Unterschied
zwischen einem selbstbestimmten Leben
oder den Abrutsch in Sozialleistungen
und für mich ist es auch eine Frage des
Respekts worüber wir ja heute reden denn
diejenigen die hart arbeiten in unserem
Land die sollen nicht aus ihrer Wohnung
fliegen weil sie sich die Miete und die
Nebenkosten nicht mehr leisten können
und nicht nur in der Krise sondern
dauerhaft und dafür ist das Wohngeld da
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir erweitern den bezieherkreis wir
verdreifachen ihnen von 600.000 auf über
2 Millionen Haushalte und wir steigern
auch die Summe und wir haben es eben
gehört von der bauministerin es wird
eine dauerhafte heizkomponente geben wir
werden mit einer klimakomponente
sicherstellen dass sich insbesondere
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen nicht
dann die schlechtesten Wohnungen mehr
leisten können sondern dass auch dafür
ein Faktor eingepreist ist und ganz
wichtig und dafür sind wir heute auch
hier wir müssen auch kommunikativ an das
Wohngeld ran viele wissen auch nicht
dass sie Anspruch haben oftmals ist es
noch in der sogenannten Schmuddelecke
und man hat Befindlichkeiten und möchte
da auch nicht unbedingt hingehen und
diesen Antrag den wir eben auch gesehen
haben der auch einfacher werden darf und
wird auszufüllen und ich finde jemand
der arbeitet der sich an die Regeln hält
in diesem Land und der trotzdem nicht
über die Runden kommt diese Menschen
haben Anspruch auf unsere Solidarität
und ja wir haben eben viel geredet über
Symptome über den Wohnungsmarkt und wir
sind uns dessen bewusst dass wir hier
mit einem Symptom bekämpfen aber wir
gehen doch natürlich auch ran an die
Wurzel des Problems vielleicht hat der
einen oder andere ja gestern mitbekommen
dass wir da drüben im Kanzleramt
gemeinsam waren mit einem Bündnis ein
Bündnis bezahlbares Wohnen dort haben
wir 67 Seiten an Maßnahmen festgelegt
damit wir jetzt ins bauen kommen und
damit es einfacher wird und damit wir
natürlich auch weiteren bezahlbaren
Wohnraum schaffen in diesem Land und
jetzt erzählen sie nicht dass wir hier
nur ein bisschen kleinkosmetik nein wir
packen das Thema Wohnen ganzheitlich an
mit einem Ministerium gemeinsam in
dieser Koalition mit Wumms und mit einem
Bündnis aus vielen Maßnahmen und vor
allen Dingen aus einem Bündnis mit
vereinten Kräften liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und ja wir haben auch im
Koalitionsvertrag einiges vereinbart
und wir haben auch noch einiges vor und
ich bin auch sehr dankbar dass der
Kollege von der FDP Buschmann mit
Hochdruck dran arbeitet dass wir auch
die mietrechtlichen Fragestellungen
gemeinsam hinbekommen denn da haben wir
natürlich auch noch jede Menge zu tun
aber wenn wir anders Wohngeld gehen wenn
wir an das Bauen gehen von bezahlbaren
Wohnraum und wenn wir eben jetzt auch
dieses Maßnahmenbündel auf dem Weg
bekommen dann bin ich optimistisch dass
wir hier niemanden alleine lassen dass
wir es gemeinsam anpacken dafür danke
ich für die konstruktive Mitarbeit und
ich sage legen wir los
das Wort erhält für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Michael Kiesling
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Fürst ich
möchte mal darauf eingehen zur
blauäugigen Energiepolitik wir haben gut
gelebt von den günstigen Energiepreisen
und Herr Scholz wusste ja schon immer
dass Putin sozusagen die Energie
verwenden wird um Krieg zu führen und
entsprechend Einfluss zu nehmen er war
damals Arbeitsminister war Vizekanzler
und Finanzminister den Kurs mitgetragen
am Anfang von Kanzler also Kanzler wurde
hat auch die Nord Stream 2 noch
verteidigt und mir scheint so sie wissen
heute schon die Fehler diese du morgen
machen testen wenn ich blaue blauäugige
Politik aber zurück
zum Thema Wohngeld Wohngeld das ist
richtig dass man das erhöht dass man es
ausbaut und das mater reformiert es ist
wichtig dass wir auf die aktuellen
Herausforderungen Antworten
Jan Marquardt lukas hat angesprochen es
kommt zu spät wir haben sie im März
bereits gefordert die Leute sind jetzt
natürlich auf der Palme und sagen wie
soll ich das denn in Zukunft Zahlen es
soll jetzt anfangen des nächsten Jahres
umgesetzt werden die Kommunen sind nicht
vorbereitet weder vom Personal noch wie
es funktionieren will es fehlt einfach
die Planungssicherheit und das fehlt der
Vorlauf das auch entsprechender Zeit
abzuarbeiten und wenn sie auch im
Gespräch sind wie wir mit den
verschiedenen Ebenen im Land und in den
Kommunen dann würden sie ihnen das auch
bestätigen dass es so ist und das ist
die Herausforderung die wir haben sie
müssen schauen dass wir das schnell sind
und die handwerklichen Fehler die dort
noch drin sind auch schnell behoben
werden so dass man das auch entsprechend
schnell auszahlen kann und verlässlich
auszahlen kann
die Erwartungen die sie für das
angefangen von neun Euro Ticket was
nicht langfristig durchgeführt werden
kann bis jetzt beim Wohngeld ist immer
sie kündigen an
sie liefern nicht sie liefern zu spät
oder es bleiben Fragen offen und das
denke ich ist nicht die Politik die wir
in Krisenzeiten benötigen
auch die endgültige Finanzierungs ist ja
noch etwas aufmacht das müssen wir
werden und dass wir eine Verdreifachung
der Berechtigten haben ist erstmal eine
gute Zahl dass mir ausgewiesen ist aber
eigentlich ist es erschütternd das wäre
dreifache Verdoppelung haben der
wohngeld-empfänger es müsste ich
eigentlich lohnen wenn man in Arbeit
geht dass man sich sozusagen mit dem
Geld was man verdient die Wohnung die
Wärme den Strom und auch des Leben
leisten kann und das sehe ich bei ihrer
Koalition überhaupt nicht gegeben das
scheint auch nicht der Anspruch ihrer
Regierung zu sein
durch die Links FDP geführte Regierung
wird es ja gerade zum Anspruch nicht zu
arbeiten
wenn man auf das Bürgergeld schaut
beispielsweise ja nichts a das haben sie
verbrochen oder wollen es Verbrechen
wenn ich nicht arbeite und dadurch mehr
Geld bekomme als wenn ich in die Arbeit
gehe dann habe ich doch ein Problem dann
rentiert sich es doch gar nicht wenn die
Arbeitsergebnis doch der falsche Anreiz
meine Dame und meine Herren
wer in die Arbeit geht der soll auch von
diesem Geld leben können und dieser
Lohnabstand und Leistungsabstand der
muss doch auch entsprechend dargestellt
werden meine Damen und Herren
so und wir haben doch die
gesellschaftliche Verantwortung zu
rechtfertigen dass mit dem Geld dass wir
von den Steuern zahlen einnehmen auf
verantwortungsvoll umgehen und auch die
nachfolgende Generationen entsprechend
bezahlen und entgegen der Meinung vor
dem einordnen grünen Abgeordneten kann
sich der Staat nicht grenzenlos
verschulden und die Zinsen selber
festlegen
Wirtschaftspolitik scheint nicht die
Stärke der Grünen zu sein meine Damen
und Herren
und damit handeln sie nicht nachhaltig
nachhaltig ist nicht nur Umwelt und
Klimaschutz nachhaltig ist auch eine
solide Haushaltspolitik und eine faire
Sozialpolitik und dies für die die das
Geld erwirtschaften und diejenige die
wir solidarisch entsprechend
unterstützen müssen meine Damen und
Herren
lassen Sie mich abschließend noch auf
einen Punkt eingehen das Wohngeld ist
ein Bestandteil unser wichtiger
Bestandteil ohne Frage es ist
zielgerichtet weil es auf den Bedarf des
Einzelnen entsprechend eingeht auf die
Größe der Wohnung auf das Einkommen und
so weiter aber wir brauchen auch
Wohnraum und das haben sie geschafft
innerhalb kürzester Zeit eine vollbremse
eine glatte vollbremse im Wohnungsmarkt
zu verursachen wir haben hohe Baukosten
wir haben hohe Energiekosten da fehlen
momentan die Antworten von der Regierung
wie reagieren Sie darauf was kann mir
entsprechend anbieten sie schrauben die
Anforderungen eine Wohnungsbau hoch und
streichen die Förderprogramme zusammen
sie vertröst mit einem lauwaren Ergebnis
des Bündnis was sie gestern vorgestellt
haben wenn wir zurückblicken hat man
Hochlauf auf 300.000 Wohnungen gebaut
worden
wir hatten Baukindergeld wir hatten
depressive aber wir hatten KfW-Förderung
jetzt fordern sie 400.000 Wohnungen und
das ganze soll funktionieren mit einem
förderchaos aller Habeck mit steigenden
Zins mit lieferengkreis mit steigen
Baukosten das glauben nicht mal ihre
Bündnispartner die gestern entsprechend
das Bündnis mit vorgestellt haben
momentan wird sie haben sie gesagt die
400.000 Wohnungen werden nicht mehr
erreichen aber sie stehen im
bündnispapier nach wie vor drin anstatt
klare Konzepte und gezielte investive
Maßnahmen wollen sie mit prüfauftragen
Evaluation runden Tischen den
wohnungsbaufördern das klingt schön aber
damit wird keine neuen Wohnungen und
zumindest nicht schnell neue Wohnungen
gebaut die wir brauchen
und eins noch sie haben völlig recht
Frau Gallwitz wenn es im bauwumms macht
dann ist was kaputt dann hat was nicht
funktioniert sie machen einen doppelwurf
sie fahren die Bauwirtschaft gegen die
Wand herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
oh und jetzt kommt
Hannah des 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kießling
ich habe wirklich versucht so zu hören
uns gehen ja um 9 Euro Ticket Bürgergeld
zwei buntes pottpariert zum Wohngeld
habe ich nicht so viel gehört deswegen
probiere ich jetzt noch mal mit dem
hohen Geld worum es ja eigentlich
wir wollen sozial gemischte Kieze das
Wohngeld wurde bereit eingeführt um
genau das zu ermöglichen damit Menschen
mit niedrigem Einkommen sich auf dem
freien Wohnungsmarkt eine Wohnung
leisten können und da wohnen wo sie
wollen das ist die Idee des Wohngeldes
und die gilt noch immer auch wenn wir
jetzt zu Recht ganz viel Entlastung
diskutiert haben und die Folgen von
Putins angriffskriegs die zu steigenden
Energiepreisen und anderen
Preisexplosionen führen also beim
Wohngeld geht es darum dass wir sozial
gemischte Kieze erhalten und wir haben
die größte wohngeldreform der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik von ihr profitieren
zwei Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
zwei Millionen Haushalt in ganz
Deutschland Rentnerinnen
Alleinerziehende Familien Studierende
Azubis und Menschen mit kleinem
Einkommen
mit Verena Hubert sind wir gerade schon
nach Trier gegangen ich würde meinen
Berlin bleiben was bedeutet das Wohngeld
konkret es bedeutet für die Rentnerin in
Berlin die eine Miete von 550 Euro hat
und ein Gesamteinkommen von 1200 Euro
sie hat bisher Anspruch auf 16 Euro
Wohngeld sehr berechtigt können wir
davon ausgehen dass sie das vermutlich
nicht beantragt hat der Auffahrt steht
in kein Verhältnis zu 16 Euro im Monat
das heißt wahrscheinlich nutzt sie es
nicht nach der Reform bekommt sie 212
Euro Wohngeld das ist fast die Hälfte
ihrer Miete
und wir wandern weiter weil Berlin ja
nicht der Nabel der Republik ist für die
Familien Heidelberg zwei Elternteile ein
Kind Miete 900 Euro Einkommen 2.800 Euro
brutto sie haben bisher keinen Anspruch
auf Wohngeld nach der Reform sind es 311
€. es macht also einen Unterschied es
bedeutet das auch ich gucke zu meinem
Kollegen Kassen hinterher sali die
alleinerziehende in Dresden
beispielsweise sichere Wohnungen noch
leisten kann und nicht umziehen muss das
ist eine ganz wichtige Veränderung durch
die Reform des wohngelds
aber es ist heute die erste Lesung des
wohngeldreformgesetzes gilt das eher
drucksche Gesetz auch wir möchten noch
einige Dinge ändern das eine wurde heute
schon vielfach thematisiert die Frage
wie wir es schaffen dass wir die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Wohngeld stellen die wirklich wichtige
Arbeit leisten nicht überfordern da
müssen wir gemeinsam als Ampel noch mal
überlegen es gibt viele Vorschläge dass
wir das noch einfacher machen das sind
wir die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern schuldig
und ich als grüne habe noch einen
zweiten Punkt
so wie die klimakomponente in diesem
Gesetzesentwurf ausgestaltet ist hat sie
mit einem sozialen Ausgleich für
energetische Sanierung noch nicht so
viel zu tun ich verstehe wir sind in
einer Situation dass wir sehr schnell
die Reform durchbringen möchten müssen
weil wir sehr schnellen Menschen
entlasten wollen das ist richtig aber
ich finde wir müssen trotzdem noch mal
überlegen was man da drehen kann oder
notfalls bei der nächsten Evaluierung
eine klimakomponente einführen die ihren
Namen dann auch wirklich gerecht wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Ziel beim Wohngeld ist es dass die
soziale Mischung erhalten bleibt dafür
nehmen wir ehrlich gesagt ganz schön
viel Geld in die Hand um Mieten zu
subventionieren aber es gibt auch andere
Wege dieses Ziel zu erreichen und an
denen müssen wir genauso arbeiten wir
brauchen eine neue wohngemeinnützigkeit
damit wir dauerhaft bezahlbaren Wohnraum
zur Verfügung stellen und
und wir müssen das
Vorkaufsrecht wieder rechtssicher
einführen damit Mieterinnen und Mieter
nicht weiter verdrängt werden dafür
werden wir uns Grüne in der Koalition
weiter einsetzen und ich freue mich auf
die Beratung von Heizkostenzuschuss und
wohngeldplus-
vielen Dank Hannah Steinmüller war das
für die Bündnis grünen der nächste
Redner in dieser Debatte die nächste
Rednerin ist Anne König von der cdu/csu
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast
auf den Tag genau vor sieben Monaten
durfte ich hier im Deutschen Bundestag
meine erste Rede zum Heizkostenzuschuss
halten seit Anfang März ist viel Zeit
vergangen und immer noch warten die
Menschen in unserem Land auf
strukturelle und spürbare Entlastung
schon damals haben wir als Union erklärt
dass ihre einmalhilfen der Wirklichkeit
hoffnungslos hinterherhinken und bei
einer immer weiter steigenden Preisen
die Kosten auch der Menschen nur minimal
abfedern ich habe im März schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die Preisexplosion
längst die gesellschaftliche Mitte
erreicht hat und es eben nicht nur
symbolische Hilfen für wenige sondern
strukturelle Lösungen für viele braucht
denn schon damals war klar dass ein
einmaliger Heizkostenzuschuss nicht
reichen wird und das ist einer
wohngeldreformbedarf mit einer inte
zweiten Klima und heizkostenkomponente
und es ist für die Menschen in diesem
Land bitter dass die allermeisten
Kritikpunkte aus dem Frühjahr heute noch
genauso zutreffend und aktuell sind wie
vor sieben Monaten denn ihre
Herangehensweise hat sich seitdem nicht
verbessert und eine Lernkurve ist bei
ihnen mit bloßem Auge auch nicht zu
erkennen aber
fangen aber fangen wir mal bei der
Wurzel des Problems an diese
Bundesregierung weigert sich hartnäckig
die Angebotsseite in der gebotenen
Konsequenz zu erhöhen und ihr ist es
nicht gelungen in sieben Monaten einen
Vorschlag auf europäischer Ebene zu
unterbreiten wie man Gas aus dem marrit
order System rausnimmt somit bleiben
Strom und Gaspreise bis auf weiteres
Hoch hinzu kommt experten sagen uns seit
Monaten voraus dass uns eine schwere
Rezession droht man kann nur hoffen dass
ihr sogenannter doppelwumms für
Industrie- und Mittelstand nicht zum
doppelfloppt wird irgendwer muss in
Zukunft die auch unsere Sozialleistungen
erwirtschaften und wir können nur mit
einer starken Wirtschaft unseren
Wohlstand erhalten
zur Zeit vergrößert ihre Politik nicht
nur den ökonomischen Schaden sondern
führt auch zu gesamtgesellschaftlichen
und sozialen Verwerfungen denken Sie
bitte auch mal darüber nach was sollen
eigentlich all diejenigen die arbeiten
gehen und keinen Wohngeld und keinen
Heizkostenzuschuss erhalten jetzt tun
auch die Unterstützung für die
arbeitende Mitte ist jetzt notwendiger
denn je
zudem braucht es für Geringverdiener und
Rentner die eben knapp oberhalb des
empfängerkreises liegen ebenfalls
Lösungen alles andere wäre ungerecht da
es sich heute um die erste Lesung
handelt und wie die Regierung im
Interesse der Menschen kritisch
konstruktiv begleiten wollen will ich
Ihnen gerne die wichtigsten Kritikpunkte
noch mal darlegen und ich tue das auch
in der Hoffnung dass sie diese dieses
Mal auch aufgreifen und endlich
Verbesserungen vornehmen erstens sowohl
der Heizkostenzuschuss als auch das
wohngeldplus in ihrer jetzigen Form
behandeln höchstens die Symptome das
Problem muss an der Wurzel gepackt
werden erweitern Sie also das
Energieangebot und reduzieren Sie
dadurch die Preise zweitens lösen sie
zumindest bei diesem Gesetz einmal ihr
Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
ein da heißt es nämlich richtigerweise
auf Seite 8 wir wollen Gesetze
verständlicher machen
stattdessen konfrontieren Sie nun den
Bürger mit folgender Formulierung aus
Anlage 3 ich zitiere das unberundete
monatliche Wohngeld ergibt sich durch
Einsetzen der Werte für ABC aus Anlage 2
und für m und Y in die Formel nach § 19
Absatz 1 Satz 1 und durch Ausführen der
vier folgenden Rechenschritte Z1 = A + B
mal m und plusc mal y Z2 = Z1 mal y Z3 =
m - Z2 und Z4 = 1,15 mal Z3 und ich sage
Ihnen ganz ehrlich damit provozieren sie
wahrscheinlich hunderttausende Anrufe
bei den wohngeldstellen vor Ort weil
niemand bei ihrem Gesetz weiß ob ihm
Wohngeld plus überhaupt zusteht sorgen
Sie da auch bitte für Klarheit
drittens insbesondere der
Heizkostenzuschuss erscheint nicht
zielgenau der festgelegte Betrag kann
sowohl in die eine als auch in die
andere Richtung stark vom tatsächlichen
Preis zum Zeitpunkt des Bedarfs
abweichen da entstehen Ungerechtigkeiten
mit Ansage während es für den einen Teil
der Empfänger ein auskömmlicher Zuschuss
sein kann weil sie gegebenenfalls in
einem energetisch guten Gebäude wohnen
wissen andere immer noch nicht wie sie
die Preisexplosion mit der Einmalzahlung
Schultern sollen wenn sie die
Betroffenen nicht zielgenauer
bezuschussen können Sie quasi jetzt
schon über das nächste
nachbesserungsgesetz nachdenken und
viertens bedauerlicherweise ist das Geld
mit der Verabschiedung von Gesetzen ja
auch noch lange nicht bei den Bürgern
der Aufgaben Zuwachs bei den
wohngeldbehörden führt durch die
Verdreifachung der Anträge zu langen
Wartezeiten pro Erstantrag für Wohngeld
werden laut ihren Ausführungen 92
Minuten benötigt und ich warne davor die
zu erwartende Antragsflut auf dem Rücken
der Mitarbeiter in den Behörden
auszutragen eine Bundesregierung die
ihre personalkörper so schamlos
aufgestockt hat wie die ihre muss es
jetzt schaffen die wohngeldbehörden
durch umschichten und abordnen von
Personal auch wirksam zu unterstützen
im übrigen braucht es auch hier eine
echte digitalisierungsoffensive damit
das Geld schneller bei den Menschen
ankommt abschließend sei gesagt handeln
sie vor allem weitsichtig sieben Monate
mussten vergehen bis sie wieder tätig
wurden und jetzt sind wir schon längst
in der Heizperiode nehmen Sie die
notwendigen Verbesserung an ihrem
Gesetzentwurf im Interesse der Menschen
vor dann sind wir auch gerne bereit
zuzustimmen aber zu einem weiter so in
ihrer unausgegorenen und unzureichenden
Krisenpolitik werden wir keinen Beitrag
leisten vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
ja mal ganz beeindruckend zu einem
Gesetzestext vorgelesen zu bekommen
Sandra Weser jetzt Vorsitzende im
Ausschuss für Wohnen Stadtentwicklung
bauen und Kommunen von der FDP
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Union sie haben ja jetzt
16 Jahre lang in der Bundes- oder die
Bundesregierung geführt und jetzt kommt
wieder das ja oder nicht schon wieder
aber ich kann es Ihnen ehrlich gesagt
nicht ersparen sie regieren in acht
Bundesländern mit sie stellen hier in
diesem Land ein ganz ordentlichen Anteil
an Landräten an Bürgermeister an
Amtsleitern und dann stellen Sie sich
hier hin Herr Kiesling und sagen und
beklagen dass die Ämter überfordert sind
und dass sie nicht in der Lage werden
den Rentnern den Teilzeitkräften den
Studenten und den Azubis in diesem Land
das Wohngeld auszuzahlen da müssen wir
uns doch die Frage stellen warum ist das
denn so ja weil sie weil sie wenn sie im
politischer Verantwortung sind keine
Modernisierung und auch keine Reform
dieser Verwaltungen angehen und weil die
Union die Digitalisierung im Bund
komplett verschlafen hat und in den
Ländern und in den Kommunen weiterhin
verschläft und sie blockieren sie auch
noch zusätzlich ja und weil ihre
Ministerpräsidentin und Präsident nichts
besseres einfällt als immer mehr nach
Steuergeld zu rufen anstatt vielleicht
auch meinem eigenen Laden effizient
aufzuräumen eins ist doch ganz klar
die Ausweitung des Wohngeldes von
600.000 Haushalten auf zwei Millionen
das ist kein Klax das ist eine
Riesenherausforderung aber es ist eben
auch ein Grund jetzt anzupacken nicht
einfach nur Hände in den Schoß sondern
jetzt heißt auch mal Ärmel hochkrempeln
auch in den Ländern und hier zählt auch
ein Stück weit die Eigenverantwortung es
gibt Lösungen unter fdp-regierungsarbeit
Herr Völs hat es eben schon mal erwähnt
haben wir 2019 in Schleswig-Holstein ein
komplett digitales Verfahren zur
Beantragung von Wohngeld für alle
Bundesländer zur Verfügung gestellt
und jetzt schauen wir mal nach Bayern
zum Herrn Kießling da gibt es ein paar
Landkreise die nutzen das aber selbst
drei Jahre später ist es auch nur ein
Bruchteil der frage ich euch regiert
denn da in Bayern und hätten sie jetzt
nicht die letzten 16 Jahre geschlafen
dann hätten wir heute diese moderne
digitale Verwaltung und dann könnten wir
jetzt in dieser Krise irgendwookratisch
und auch schnell helfen geht aber leider
nicht und ich will jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen die Meter Ebene ansprechen wir
haben in Estland ein Leuchtturm wir
können das sehen dass alle relevanten
Daten in diesem Land ob das Einkommen
ist ob das Anzahl der Kinder ist die
Sozialleistung die Kontoverbindung alle
schon längst in einem zentralen
digitalen bürgerkonto erfasst sind und
dort kann man einfach mit einem
online-eintrag jede staatliche Leistung
beantragen und die werden dann auch
online geprüft und sowas brauchen wir
hier auch in Deutschland und wir
brauchen hier einen zentrales digitales
bürgerkonto und wo wir
im Prinzip dauernd dem anstatt den
Wohngeldantrag noch mal per papierfirma
auszufüllen einfach dann digital
reinstellen und innerhalb von einer
halben Stunde auch genehmigt bekommen
das wäre der Weg den wir gerne gehen
würden vor allen Dingen die FDP und ich
denke mal da kommen wir hin wenn alle
Bundesländer mitziehen und wenn wir uns
nicht immer wieder auf diese
ineffiziente Kleinstaaterei zurückziehen
würden
als ersten Schritt in die richtige
Richtung sollten wir hier
Parallelstrukturen abbauen das heißt
Verwaltungen Auszahlung von Wohngeld
zusammenlegen mit der Grundsicherung das
heißt eine Behörde ein Datensatz ein
digitales bürgerkonto und die Kommunen
wären soeben von den wohngeldanträgen
auch entlastet das heißt diese Menschen
die dann entlastet würden die könnten
sich vielleicht auch mal um die
Baugenehmigung für neue Wohnungen
kümmern wäre auch effizient und das
heißt im Ernst also das kleine Estland
macht es uns doch hier jetzt wirklich
vor und wenn die Ministerpräsidenten im
Land wirklich mal diesen Weg gehen
würden dem Bund die Kompetenzen für ein
digitales bürgerkonto zu übertragen dann
fliege ich persönlich morgen mit ihnen
nach Estland und dann fragen ob wir da
eben auch die Software zur Verfügung
gestellt bekommen herzlichen Dank
Sandra Wieser war das für die FDP
den nächste Redner rein Niklas Nicoles
von der SPD
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren vielleicht
eine kurze Vorbemerkung vorab ich schäme
mich nicht links zu sein und links zu
sitzen ich würde mich aber schämen wie
Sie Herr Kießling sich hier den
Antidemokraten im Parlament anzubiedern
mit solchen Äußerungen die Sie getätigt
haben
Wohngeld und Bürgergeld gehören zusammen
und wir haben ja noch etwas
parlamentarische Beratungszeit um das zu
verdeutlichen mit dem Wohngeld haben wir
ein wirksames sozialpolizistinstrument
es sorgt direkt und zielgenau für
Entlastungen
48 Prozent der aktuell wohngeldbeben
sind Rentnerinnen 40 Prozent sind
Familien davon viele Alleinerziehende
mit der Reform haben wir genau diese
Menschen im Blick
ein Rentner in Berlin muss von seinem
von seiner kleinen Rente hier leben eine
vierköpfige Familie in Tübingen muss
ihre Wohnung bezahlen mit 1000 Euro
Kaltmiete
ein alleinstehende Friseurin zum
Beispiel Datteln arbeitet Vollzeit und
verdient jetzt 12 Euro den neuen
Mindestlohn was haben all diese Personen
gemeinsam
auf den ersten Blick vielleicht nicht so
viel doch sie alle haben ein kleines
Einkommen ihnen allen helfen
Steuersenkungen nicht sie alle werden
jetzt dank des wohngeldplusses dauerhaft
und kräftig entlastet bei dem Wohnkosten
die Familien Tübingen hat jetzt Anspruch
auf über 800 Euro Wohngeld im Monat also
über 300 Euro mehr im Monat als vorher
der Rentner erhält bisher rund 75 Euro
künftig sind es 250 Euro im Monat und
die alleinstehende Friseurin sie erhält
mit dem Wohngeld plus-gesetz jetzt
erstmal einen Wohngeldanspruch und mit
dem Wohngeldrechner ist das leicht zu
überprüfen
genau für diese Menschen ist das
Wohngeld da das Wohngeld ist ein
Wohnkostenzuschuss für Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen egal ob sie zum Miete
wohnen oder im Wohneigentum Menschen die
trotz harter Arbeit am Ende des Monats
an den hohen Wohnkosten verzweifeln
Menschen die sich diesen Anspruch aufs
Wohngeld erarbeitet haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Menschen zu entlasten ist eine Frage des
Respekts
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir nun das
Wohngeld Plus auf dem Weg bringen es ist
ein Teil von vielen milliardenschweren
Maßnahmen die unsere Regierung unter
oder Scholz auf dem Weg gebracht hat
ich wünschte ich wünschte dass ich die
Landesregierung meines Bundeslandes NRW
daran auch mal ein Beispiel nimmt in der
Krise heißt es machen statt meckern oder
zumindest nicht im Weg stehen wenn der
Bund voran geht
und und der Kollege luca hat jetzt hier
viel gesagt was schneller gehen muss was
anders geben muss aber ich habe keinen
einzigen konkreten Vorschlag gehört wir
das eigentlich machen möchte außer ein
ein Forscher kann ich gehört wie deshalb
bei der klimakomponente noch
komplizierter wird und noch länger zu
prüfen ist das ist ein
Widersprüchlichkeit nicht zu überbieten
meine Damen und Herren
für die schnelle und ambitionierte und
wichtige Erarbeitung des
Gesetzesentwurfs danke ich unsere
Ministerin und den gesamten Haus
herzlich meine Vorrednerinnen haben die
wichtigen Verbesserungen schon
ausführlich da gestellt
heizkostenkomponente klimakomponente und
eine Erhöhung der Leistung das alles
kommt rein ohne dass das
Antragsverfahren komplexer wird
zentral ist auch die massive Ausweitung
der Leistungsberechtigten rund 2
Millionen Haushalte können zukünftig das
Wohngeld beantragen es ist ein
wesentlicher Baustein zur Abfederung der
Krise dafür ist es entscheidend dass das
Geld direkt bei den Menschen ankommt
und deshalb nehmen all den guten Dingen
die schon drin sind die wir hier in
Berlin beschließen vor allem die
Umsetzung vor Ort
ich habe in den letzten Wochen auch wie
einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
angesprochen haben auch mit der Praxis
gesprochen in dem wohngeldstellen
Gespräche geführt und ich verstehe dass
durch die vielen Neuanträge im nächsten
Jahr weitere Arbeit auf sie zukommt
deswegen sind zwei Dinge jetzt ganz
wichtig
erstens wir alle sind uns einig es
braucht Vereinfachung damit Anträge
schneller geprüft werden können und das
Geld schneller bei den Menschen ankommen
da sind aber Bund und Länder gemeinsam
in der Pflicht wir werden hier genau
hinsehen und prüfen welche
praxisstauglichen Vereinfachungen noch
möglich sind
zweitens wir brauchen in dem
wohngeldstellen eine vernünftige
personelle Ausstattung und hier geht
mein Appell ganz besonders an die Länder
sie müssen doch ihre Kommunen in die
Lage versetzen Stellen zu schaffen und
zu besetzen
denn es ist klar zum erfolgreichen
Umsetzung dieser Reform müssen wir alle
an einem Strang ziehen und ich hoffe
dass das im parlamentarischen Verfahren
noch gelingt wird
zum Schluss liegt mir eine Sache
besonders am Herzen wir befreien das
Wohngeld mit diesem Gesetz vom
verstaubten Image liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger machen sie Gebrauch von ihrem
Anspruch sie haben sich den Anspruch
erarbeitet und verdient und wer was
anderes sagt macht Politik auf Kosten
auf ihre Kosten und das finde ich
schäbig herzlichen Dank
ja alles auf das Wohnmobil zu verzichten
das sollte man in der Tat nicht tun 540
Euro sind das für einen zwei
Personenhaushalt
Anja nein
vielen Dank dass ich so oft erwähnt
haben ich glaube ich bin keiner
Bundestagsdebatte ist auf der Welt
worden wie in dieser aber zu ihrer
möchte ich schon noch was sagen was ist
falsch an den Wunsch die Menschen aus
den Sozialleistungen zu führen und dass
die vor dem selbst verdienten Geld auch
leben können das muss doch unser
Anspruch sein ich muss doch unser
Anspruch sein dass ich wenn ich Geld
verdiene das sind Arbeitsplatz habe und
davon leben kann das hat doch nicht mit
rechts und links zu tun das muss doch
der Anspruch sein einer demokratisch
gewählten Partei dass sich Leistung
lohnen muss
möchten sie reagieren bitte sehr
gehe ich sehr gerne ich habe sie an
einer Stelle angesprochen genau das ist
richtig und ich glaube sie haben
verkannt an welchem Punkt ich sie
angesprochen habe ich finde es
unanständig die Bürgergeld Diskussion in
diesem Kontext einzubringen als würden
wir eben die Menschen die hart arbeiten
dadurch benachteiligen ich frage mich
warum haben Sie nicht zugestimmt als es
um den Mindestlohn ging wo man ganz
konkret hätte helfen können das was Sie
angesprochen haben in Realität
umzusetzen und entschuldigen Sie aber
wenn Sie den sprech der AFD übernehmen
dann benenne ich das ganz deutlich und
dann dann dann tut es mir leid ich habe
das in der Bürger der gelddebatte auch
schon verfolgt dass sie in der Union zu
Recht darauf sehr allergisch reagieren
aber wenn sich den zu anziehen dann
dürfen Sie nicht sich wundern wenn sie
danach benannt werden deswegen war es
für mich sehr wichtig diesen Unterschied
deutlich zu machen wenn das dazu
beiträgt dass sie Umdenken das was sie
vorgetragen haben auch dann so in
Zukunft äußern und da an dieser Politik
an einer Oppositionsarbeit konstruktiv
ist und die in der Krise verlässlich ist
mitwirken dann hat ja mein Wortbeitrag
und dass ich sie direkt angesprochen
habe schon etwas positiv bewirkt und da
würde ich mich sehr freuen
und jetzt hat Anja Liebert das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bundesregierung hat ja in den
vergangenen Monaten bereits eine
Vielzahl sozialpolitischer Maßnahmen und
Entlastungen auf den Weg gebracht denn
wir nehmen die Sorgen und die Nöte der
Menschen vor den steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten und natürlich auch
vor den massiv steigenden heiz- und
Wohnkosten ernst und eine bezahlbare
angemessene und sichere Wohnung zählt zu
den Grundbedürfnissen aller Menschen
und mit der geplanten Erweiterung des
Kreises der wohngeldberechtigen
Berechtigten adressieren wir ja sehr
viele verschiedene Gruppen
kleine Menschen mit kleinen Renten
geringverdienende Alleinerziehende und
größere Familien aber die wohngeldreform
ist auch ein Instrument der
Stadtentwicklungspolitik unser Ziel ist
es nämlich dass Menschen mit mittleren
und niedrigen Einkommen nicht an den
Rand gedrängt werden an den Stadtrand
oder an den Rand wo es eben bestimmte
wohnensituationen gibt sondern auch ein
Krankenpfleger oder die Servicekraft in
der Gastronomie müssen sich das wohnen
dort leisten können im Zentrum wenn Sie
mögen ohne lange Pendelwege zur Arbeit
in Kauf zu nehmen
und unser Leitbild der Stadtentwicklung
sind die lebendigen Quartiere mit einer
vielfältigen Nutzung da gehört Arbeiten
Wohnen Freizeit und Erholung unmittelbar
zusammen es muss aber auch eine Mischung
unterschiedlicher Milieus sein
unterschiedlicher Lebensstile und
unterschiedlicher Einkommensgruppen und
dafür ist natürlich auch die
wohngeldreform da dass wir diese
nutzungsgemischte Stadt erhalten können
die wohngeldreform hilft aber auch den
Kommunen und insbesondere den
finanzschwachen Kommunen denn diese
werden finanziell von den Ausgaben für
die Sozialhilfe deutlich entlastet und
das schon im nächsten Jahr mit ca 200
Millionen Euro
und 380.000 Haushalte werden aus dem SGB
II Bezug also dem Bezug vom Jobcenter
und der Grundsicherung in den
Wohngeldbezug wechseln und auch das
entlastet die Kommunen deutlich und wir
müssen mittelfristig natürlich unsere
Kommunen beim Bürokratieabbau bei einem
vereinfachten Antragsverfahren und auch
mit Hilfe von Digitalisierung das wurde
ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen
deutlich unterstützen und im
Gesetzentwurf
im Gesetzentwurf sind ja auch schon
einige Maßnahmen vorgestellt wie man den
verarbeitungsaufwand in den Kommunen
reduzieren kann durch die Verlängerung
des Bewilligungszeitraums von 12 auf 18
Monate und mit sinnvollen
übergangszeiträumen von einem ins andere
System und damit können wir den Ämtern
Luft verschaffen und es wird trotzdem
eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe für die
Kommunen diese Reform umzusetzen wir
müssen daher auch an einer besseren
Finanzausstattung für die Kommunen
arbeiten und wir Grünen setzen uns
gemeinsam in der Ampel natürlich auch
für eine Lösung der
altschuldenproblematik finanzwocher
Kommunen ein denn wir brauchen
Ausstattung und Personal in den Kommunen
vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion ist der Kollege
Martin Diedenhofen das der nächste
Redner würde ich sagen ja und Martin
Dietenhofen von SPD ist der letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Ministerin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 kommt
Heizkostenzuschuss zwei wir kennen es
aus der Filmbranche ist ein Film
erfolgreich wird schnell ein zweiter
Teil nachgelegt obwohl wir erst im
Frühjahr des den ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss verabschiedet haben
reden wir heute schon über Teil 2 aber
anders als in der Filmbranche kamen wir
den zweiten Teil leider nicht weil wir
als Regierungskoalition vom Erfolg des
ersten Teils profitieren möchten wir
machen das weil es aufgrund der
aktuellen Situation ganz dringend
notwendig ist
beim zweiten Teil werden wir auch wie
bei Filmen üblich nochmal drauflegen und
planen jetzt mit 415 Euro das ist bitter
notwendig damit Wohngeld und
bafög-empfängerinnen und Empfänger eine
Chance haben über die Runde zu kommen
denn die dicke Rechnung wird spätestens
in den kalten Monaten eintrudeln und
deswegen ist für die SPD-Fraktion auch
vollkommen klar wir dürfen diese
Menschen nicht im Regen stehen lassen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das heißt auch und da wende ich mich
auch noch mal an die Unionsfraktion dass
das Geld schnell zu den Menschen kommen
muss in meiner Heimat Rheinland-Pfalz
ist das längst geschehen auch die
anderen SPD-geführten Bundesländer haben
ihre Hausaufgaben gemacht und den ersten
Heizkostenzuschuss bereits ausgezahlt
ganz im Gegensatz übrigens zu den
unionsgeführten Ländern wie
beispielsweise Bayern und da sage ich
ganz klar vielleicht sollte Herr Söder
nicht nur heiße Luft produzieren sondern
auch mal wirklich etwas für die Menschen
in diesen Krisenzeiten machen
bei Filmen kommt nach einem ersten und
einem zweiten Teil häufig sogar noch ein
dritter oder ein vierter Teil wir haben
aber anderes vor was das Wohngeld angeht
wir werden nämlich quasi eine Serie
nachlegen im Zuge der wohngeldreform
werden wir nicht nur den Empfängerinnen
und Empfängerkreis massiv ausweiten
sondern eine dauerhafte
heizkostenkomponente einführen und dann
wissen die Menschen auch klar womit Sie
rechnen können
sie kennen sicher diese Filme bei denen
man schon am Anfang weiß dass es ein
Happy End geben wird und auch wie das
aussehen wird in der aktuellen Krise
können wir das nicht sagen das gehört zu
Wahrheit dazu und das Blaue vom Himmel
zu versprechen das überlasse ich an der
Stelle auch lieber der Opposition was
wir aber versprechen können als Ampel
dass wir alles geben dafür die
zusätzlichen Belastungen so gut wie
möglich abzufedern und dass wir
niemanden diesem Land alleine lassen
herzlichen Dank
dann schieße ich jetzt die Aussprache
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Gesetzentwurf Würfe auf den Drucksachen
39 36 und 38 84 an die in der
Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschusses
vorgeschlagen ich sehe keine anderen
Wünsche dann ist das so beschlossen